hey guys it is Tuesday the 17th of move
em but today my name is Jess McDonald
and here's the cool stuff it happened
again today independent research group
super data are estimating the full up
for digital sales hit 1.8 million in
first three days the group reported that
1.2 million units were sold on PC
primarily via Steam while the remainder
was sold through the xbox marketplace
and the PlayStation Store super Dada's
yo Steve Andrew and said that digital
sales are full at fort generated one
hundred million dollars in revenue which
he says proves that PC gamers will shell
out from price for SELEX titles and
won't necessarily wait exclusively for
massive steam or Humble Bundle sales on
launch day but those reported that they
had shipped 12 million fallout 4 copies
to retailers worldwide which represented
sales in excess of 750 million bucks hey
building a brand new gigantic action
game according to CFO Blakey yoga son
yogen sarah said that Jade Raymond who
created Assassin's Creed was brought on
a TA in part to help the company move
into this genre he explained we never
really operated in the largest genre of
gaming and that's the action genre
that's the Assassin's Creed style games
laura's World War single play vs.
multiplayer we're recently hired Jade
Raymond who is behind the Assassin's
Creed franchise for Ubisoft and she will
be building an action game for us
through a studio we're building out in
Montreal right now that new studio is
motive Studios who also brought on
uncharted writer Amy Hennig and are
currently working on visceral games as
new Star Wars title among other things
finally the internet conspiracy machine
may or may not have a cup of the name of
Mass Effect Andromeda protagonist as
reported by Eurogamer reddit user
Bernalillo spotted a dog tag on the left
side of the screen 44 seconds into the
iOS recent 2015 and
de trailer the dog tag appears to read
wider and the user proposed that the
protagonist could be named after Sally
Ride the first American woman in space
given that Shepard was named after Alan
Shepard the first American men in space
that logic kinda checks out by oh well
Montreal studio director gana Croix also
said that there was apparently a very
good reason for their choice of songs in
Andromeda's announcement trailer that
song was Johnny Cash's rendition of
ghost riders in the sky interesting
let me know down in the comments of your
came for ea's take on an open-world
action game you can add the game thought
we've got stories on for two suitors
microtransactions and EA talking
next-generation consoles that is
everything i have for you today as
always let me know what matter to you
and I will catch you again tomorrow